countries don't get better now I want to
speak directly to the young men and
women of color in this country who is
plan just so eloquently described they
have witnessed too much violence and too
much debt and
too often some of that violence has come
from folks who were supposed to be
serving and protecting you I want you to
know that you matter I want you to know
that your lives matter that your dreams
matter and when I go home and I look at
the faces of my daughter Sasha and Malia
and I look at my nephews and nieces I
see limitless potential that deserves to
flourish and thrive and you should be
able to learn and make mistakes and live
a life of joy without having to worry
about what's gonna happen when you walk
to the store or go for a jog or are
driving down the street we're looking at
some birds in a park and and and so I
hope that you also feel how hopeful even
as you may feel angry because you have
the power to make things better and you
have helped to make the entire country
feel as if this is something that's got
to change you've communicated a sense of
urgency that is as powerful and as
transformative as anything that I've
seen in recent years I want to
acknowledge the folks in law enforcement
that share the goals of reimagining
policing because there are folks out
there who took their oath to serve your
communities in your countries have a
tough job and I know you're just as
outraged about tragedies in recent weeks
as our many of the protesters and so
we're grateful for the vast majority of
you who protect and serve I've been
heartened to see those in law
enforcement who recognized
let me March along with these protesters
let me stand side-by-side and recognize
that I want to be part of the solution
and who've shown restraint and
volunteered and engaged and listened
because you're a vital part of the
conversation and and change is going to
require everybody's participation